[Music]
abigail is with us in austin texas hey
abigail how are you
hi dave i'm great thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
so i own three rental properties
and one of them i own with my ex-husband
i own 75 he owns 25 percent
joyful and well
he and i we actually we get along very
well he's a realtor i'm a realtor we see
eye to eye so there's no disharmony
around the management
of the property but so so the
deal is this uh because i'm interested
to know what you would do in this
situation
given that interest rates are so low i
inquired with my mortgage banker about
refinancing so right now it's at four
and a half percent
and she told me we could get down to
2.625
but at that time my ex-husband said you
know you want to buy me out
because he you know he's like i don't
want to refinance and extend the loan
whatever
so she did let me know that we could
roll it all
in together the problem is that
uh so the house is the value is
somewhere around 400 to 425
and so my share would be around 100 and
when i
just run the numbers um
it looks like i would negative cash flow
by a couple
thousand dollars per year if i took on
that additional
debt load and so um
and so you know i just wanted to get
your your opinion about what you would
do in the circumstance my ex-husband is
fine to continue
as is you know not refinancing
um so what is the current mortgage is
200
the the balance you you mean your
current balance today is what
120 120 okay all right
all right i'm coming up on the clock
hang on we come back from this break
we'll talk this through with you all
right abigail let me go back and make
sure i got my numbers right because my
head's spinning a little bit here you
got a rental property you own with your
ex it's worth 400
you owe 120. you own 75 he owns 25
you're talking about uh refinancing from
an interest rate in the high fours to an
interest rate down in the twos which
makes a lot of sense he doesn't want to
do that
but in it while it all came up he said
hey just buy me out
is that what you told me that's all
that's exactly correct
and you told me that if you were to
refinance and buy him out
that um that you would be negative
cash flowing per year okay
well that's where i got lost because
let's see here you've got a 280 thousand
dollar equity
but you should not be buying him out on
the 280 000 you should buy them out
based on
two based on 400 minus about 40 for
expenses
and so you've got about a 240 thousand
dollar equity is that sound about right
um uh i got lost there
okay okay if you're buying a partner out
on a piece of real estate you don't do
it at retail
you do it at what it would be net in a
sale
and so if you sell a 400 000 piece of
property you got a real estate agency
you wouldn't might not have the
commissions
but the commissions you would have made
if you paid out a commission
and you had other miscellaneous expenses
and you negotiated a little bit
uh the 400 would be discounted by about
10
at least you wouldn't net and you might
net 90
of the gross amount right
okay and so that'd be 40 000 off and
you've got a 280 000
equity so there's a 240 000 equity so
his portion is only worth about
60.
okay see how i did i mean that's fair
that's not ripping him off that's not
ripping you off
nobody's getting a deal here but uh you
know i have the same thing set up in my
estate plan if
uh because i've got a bunch of real
estate if one of the kids wants to buy
out
one of the other kids on a piece of
property so they don't have to own it
together
uh they do it at an eighty percent ratio
hmm because because it's not fair to do
it at full appraisal it's not
that that's craziness because that's not
the way they because they can't get that
they can't get full appraisal net net
net so anyway 60
and 120 is only 180
of a mortgage on 400 i do not understand
why that property is not cash flowing
okay well uh in that i mean
in that scenario i mean that changes
things if i i was thinking that i would
be
um adding a hundred thousand dollars to
the
balance well there's no way it's a
hundred thousand
this is 280 at the most
so just so so you're saying this is
because you have to
there's that it's the equity versus
uh the balance in other words yeah
you're buying out
your value because it is the equity
because the only thing if you guys sell
it
you get 75 of the equity he gets 25 of
the equity after expenses agreed
right yep and so his 25 is only worth 25
of the equity after expenses
that's what his position's worth your
positions were 75
of that that's you know if you if you
were in a court for instance and this
was a
negative breakup that's how the judge
would make you calculate it
because that's a that's the proper way
of doing it because if you guys put it
on the market and sell it that's what
you're going to net
he's going to net about 60. right
okay and so anyway at
at a hundred and 120 000 mortgage today
plus 60 or plus even 80 which is not
which is too much
that's only 200 000 mortgage on a 400
000 property that should cash flow
okay um i don't know
unless this property is is the rental
market in this particular neighborhood
sucking
no no no no no i mean i'm getting right
now i mean it definitely cash flows
right now i'm getting
at the it's actually two houses on one
lot and combined it
24.50 total rent that's not much on the
400 000
value um
well actually you're correct but we've
we've had very long-term tenants
and so to the point that you're
discounted your your rental by
uh i mean that thing ought to be making
one percent a month anyway you ought to
be making four grand on that
well actually no
and maybe you need to sell this property
you may need to sell this property
because your cash on cash return or your
internal rate of return on this after
you're doing noi and everything
as deeply as you've got this thing
discounted this is not a good property
i wouldn't i wouldn't hold that yeah and
abigail i'm going to tell you pure
not even based on numbers based on life
based on on simplifying your life and
putting you in the driver's seat
is i'm not going to own a property with
an ex i'm not
and so you know i'm gonna either buy out
as dave was talking about
i'm gonna sell this thing uh just real
simple
there's no reason for you to have to
continue to go around and around and i
know things are going well right now
but you and i both know it's just gonna
take a hiccup
it's just gonna take something for old
stuff to come back clean your life out
get this thing get it gone and then you
can go buy a home the right way well
there's
like three or four different things
going on here there's that
and that's a reason to get rid of it
we've got to get the calculation if
you're going to do the buyout
down to what it should be and not
overpay
for the buyout and so at least a 10
percent discount on your gross
reducing your your equity by 40 grand
and then the uh the third problem is
discovered late in the phone call and
that is is that you guys are not making
very good money on this property
if you have four hundred thousand
dollars invested in a piece of property
you need to be grossing 3500 4 000 a
month
on that uh in most markets in austin
texas is not a bad market
so you ought to be making somewhere in
that
uh approaching one percent a month on it
in top line
in order to have justified tying up that
much money
into something so the and i i listen i
got a lot of property if i have a
long-term renter
i don't always get full market right but
i'm not running at 60 percent of market
ever well i think the thing she was
trying to wrap her head around this dave
you just gave
her a phd in real estate and she's a
realtor uh
and me too just looking at this and
talking about how to discount it before
you sell it
and so you know that's not something
everybody knows uh and being aware of
because you're right you are going to
have fees you are going to have expenses
so you can't just do a straight 25 or
whatever it is
in someone else's position i mean that
would be the deal of the year for him
it would be a great